morning Millennials good morning
Millennials
welcome to Braves season because I am
not wearing makeup did you notice no I
thought you were gonna say something
Chloe from your $1,000 math everyone
thinks okay I did a face mask last night
it was one of those ones 24 karat which
is like always fake and he like came in
a PR package and I just like ripped it
open and started using it and then I
found out that the [ __ ] face mask it
cost $1,000 and it could have resold it
on eBay for like two thousand on
everyone's but it really works like your
skin is glowing no we got spray tans
last night sorry just got back from
Miami then I just got back from Miami so
I was kissed by God so your skin is
looking glowing and the only thing you
don't have is eye makeup and the amount
that I put on yesterday but this morning
yeah I might as well not be wearing any
either yet like honestly I just didn't
have it in me today to sit down and do
my makeup again like I find I go through
phases with my makeup either I'm like so
excited to do it and like try new things
or like I can't be bothered to even sit
down and look in the mirror and that's
me today except so many [ __ ] pimples
from all the flying also it is airport
day and judging by loafers and a
sweatshirt vibe wait I said funny be
excited to do your makeup so yesterday I
went on another fruitless journey to go
shopping you did yes because I wanted to
get something from for the CMAs this
time I went to Bloomingdale's and there
was nothing for me there and you know
what's crazy is like they're still not
done doing construction and the holiday
season is here promise what and I feel
bad trash-talking every department store
in New York City they made that like I
came in I knew exactly what I needed and
I was willing to spend this amount again
just credit card at the ready nothing so
you get minutes so I went out what I
wound up only getting food at 40 carats
of course didn't want it to be a total
fail of course but I went down to the
makeup floor needing new foundation
knowing exactly what I wanted color
shade ready to purchase waving around my
money no one could be less helpful I
asked for the color they're like they're
pretending for it we don't have a tester
like forget it you don't deserve me Oh
goodbye I said good day sir good day I'm
sorry but that happened to you but I
thought it you would be really
interested to know that on my time hop
today in history I wore the exact same
outfit I was watching I did I was in
Toronto this time last year doing social
media we gonna make did this
presentation or whatever and I wore this
sweater leggings
and I had boots the boots are different
but this way but the sweater and the
leggings are the same and like I really
was ashamed well you're so clear
consistent actually that's kind of cool
because you usually look back on old
pictures and you're like damn I can't
believe I wore that well no I look back
and I'm like I can't believe my face was
that big right I can you can't believe
old chin was around mr. chin he's
scratching his belly waddling in he
hadn't been a mutant axe yes it totally
you should do crossover yeah sync up
vertical integration we're just
finishing each other's sandwiches today
really I could go for a sandwich
I'm so tired so much and so much nothing
and I mean that's the worst okay so
we're on Olivia's bachelorette party
this weekend and we did a whole vlog
it'll be up on the patreon I'm editing
it today I think it might be our best
funniest work yet
well I like I ate everything but nothing
like I ate everything there was nothing
I did a long tour but I was hungry the
whole time and I didn't like have proper
meals like I'm just I'm so tired because
I like I have not stopped traveling but
also like I'm malnourished and you
wouldn't think that if you looked at me
but I am no it's like I feel fat but
also but not like I still needed to take
my vitamins you know you just I'm gonna
eat a lot I don't take vitamins because
like don't worry I got plenty of calcium
in all the chocolate I eat mm-hmm but I
didn't get like I ate so many french
fries
yeah and that stuff really does like
weigh you down physically but like I
just I couldn't be bothered to make good
choices no and then we went to prime 112
which we finished that weekend out at
prime 112 which I'm still [ __ ] out
the creamed corn
but it was worth it I'm still laughing
from all the jokes so any joke there was
so many there was so much laughter this
weekend we're so funny sometimes no no
we are so funny sometimes and then like
sometimes it's just like we were tired
and like it wasn't that funny but it was
but then when you get tired you're like
insane yeah of course like when it's
snaps night race you were you be so
[ __ ] crazy that last night like if
it's just like a long weekend and I'm
dead basically is what we're trying to
say and if we tried to explain the jokes
do you like you wouldn't even understand
just know that snitch snaps my wrists
and stroll my Co party how is your wrist
feeling it's feeling better because I've
been getting it a break like it's taken
the day off you should get like a sling
but this morning
at my bag and I realized it wasn't
totally healed yet we came up with an
amazing idea for hallmark movie that we
did yes that is so good it's called
counselor at Christmas and it's about a
camp for any counselor obviously no
Gloria it was good and the counselor
comes home with the camper for Christmas
and like to spend time with her family
and she falls in love with the campers
older brother
yeah or dad depending on how all the
counselors yeah but if it's Mitch's
older brother
yeah and then the counselor and camper
become sisters oh that's cute
isn't that cute I think I must have
fallen asleep before they ending sneaks
up semester Jane I don't even know
what's going on right now I don't even
remember cuz I like I said I have
dementia and - I'm tired also glad that
I checked it was goodbye they it was
this time last year where you claim I
said you get on a plane this is how I
know that you are even more wrong
because it wasn't this time last year it
was CMA fest in June hello
so your point friend said but today we
will get on a plane and end up in a new
land the land of national the village of
Nash but Miami was great we stayed at
the Cadillac Hotel which was new and it
was very lovely and clean and that's
truly all you could ask her and then tbg
told me he's staying there so I'm like
oh it's TBG approved
totally excuse me I got a little quarter
I got a little wrapped up I had never
been to Miami before that was an
experience um my experience was positive
and everything about it was positive but
it also on my quest to find the best
city in America for me it is not the one
oh my god no it's so not free it is so
far from the city I believe so far from
what you're looking for but I really
embraced the Miami vibes like honestly
Miami is like what like the
personification of like a UTI is do you
know what I mean like Miami is a walking
UTI
and I definitely I I was afraid I was
gonna get one on your Bachelorette and
now after Olivia's and like being in
Miami going to add a party like I am
100% on my way to getting a TI so I'm
[ __ ] hard with you Korra's Miami needs
to be sponsored by you Cora um and in
the airport and it's like they just keep
it
clean when they give you water it all
has like a little you court and a you
Cora is it's a powder that you put like
you can mix into your water it makes it
taste like pink lemonade and it's
preventive for UTIs so I've been like
really like paranoid that I'm gonna get
one so I started to use it and Miami
Airport it's like the American Airlines
Arena is where the Miami Heat play hub
but it should be the you Korra Arena and
by the way if you want to get some new
quarter to you can say goodbye to UTIs
right now you core is offering 30% off
when you text toast two four eight four
eight four eight but hurry it's a
limited time offer text toast two four
eight four eight four eight to get
thirty percent off your order of you
Cora that's TOA st two four eight four
eight four eight yeah of a clean machine
well you're going on any clear machines
team if you're going on a bachelor party
soon I would recommend some you core
like when you do the whole presentation
of like the sassy sandwiches and the
rings and the BS is and the you Cora no
I get bowl of you core check I can tell
you like I'm so happy for you know
Olivia like my sisters it's the happiest
times in their lives but please don't
have another about try party like don't
you might mean anything ever again okay
I'll come to letting off thanks buddy
like any here we can go back to the
homines oh yeah yeah yeah like I the
dirty jeans store has been an amazing
humbling gratifying experience but it is
ruined trouble for me I never even want
to go on vacation again really yeah cuz
I have to take a plane to get there you
would think it would make chopped like
the more you travel the less of a big
deal it is I can't put a no stripper you
mean we went in a strip club like a
hundred times we get the same no it is
the same exists the strip club did you
did you engage with the strippers um yes
I gave him my money and then more than
that more than putting my money in their
breasts
I was hyping up the rest of the crowd
and the guy who was working there who
supervises the strippers he was like so
he was like yeah like yes and I was like
come on guys like I was taking my
ruining a promoter I was in the printer
taking my $1 I was really like just I
was a height man for the strippers and I
really think they appreciated it but I
was assuming as I was trying to empower
them like a lot of the men around me
were just like being so nasty and like
when they put when they gave money they
also feel entitled to touch the
strippers which is not true so I was
like just placing money like nicely and
I was being like you look great are you
working out you look amazing
where's she from
I was being conversational you know yeah
complimentary complimentary if you will
I just I thinking back to like the
beginning of the weekends like it was
just such a long weekend of thought eNOS
oh my god our dresses are levels of
thought like no bounds because if like
our plan going in was like I want to be
the biggest thought in Miami and and you
know what that was hard no we show up to
our first engagement at the first
restaurant and we were outside it
immediately right for even before we've
been 7 to the building no right right we
were like we we knew we were the Saudis
we're like oh my god people are gonna
stare at us like literally if he
wouldn't look twice at us these girls in
Miami like it wasn't fair because it
came so natural to them like we were
acting we were in a theme we were in
costume like they were just being
themselves and like Saudi this is an
attitude and honestly we did not possess
it no Jay even with her even with Margo
well that was so funny be partied all
day on Saturday and then we we needed to
go get wigs but because like no time
because of you were like just partying
so we got wasted and went wig shopping
and it was so funny and we also went to
the store next door that was I don't
know what it was called it was called
like strippers it was super Zara it's
called a super Zara
you are Miami we wanted the I wanted to
get a team I wanted the thought ease
stress that there was I basically about
three dresses that just fit barely like
that was my criteria like we were so
drunk it zips it fits and we bought
these dresses and we went back to the
hotel me like napped and laid down and
before we got ready for the night we had
like sobered up and I tried on the dress
isn't like two out of three of them were
just just not even an option I ripped
that while putting them on and the third
one I wore and it was such a small dress
like I wore Margo's clothes the whole
trip that's when you know that you've
your peak thought yeah as Ali Mohajir
says we were living in Scotland eeeh
it's a great place to be I won't be
going back anytime soon Nashville is not
that land yeah oh my god I can't wait oh
so like repro am I gonna forget to
cancel massages please remind me
reprogramming my brain to be from like
Miami to Nashville it's proven to be
difficult but I think I've struck the
right balance in my suitcase oh my god
my suitcase doesn't know what's going on
because I'm also doing a show
sorry sold out you can't go thinking
about that while I was packing and I was
like you're my hero
no I'm my own hero and like I had to
shove my stupid [ __ ] slippers but I'm
gonna wear my slippers on the red carpet
like after we like like take pictures
and stuff I'm just gonna take my shoes
off because I can't do all those
hard-hitting interviews I can't talk to
Tim McGraw in my Steve Madden shoes
totally I need to talk to him in my
Amazon slippers oh that's in my suitcase
or three couture gowns and pajamas yeah
no [ __ ] I don't have like pajamas
totally around it I actually I bought
two big t-shirts this time because the
t-shirt you gave me I can almost wore it
today like I wash it at least I gave you
a t-shirt to enjoy Thomas we were so out
of tune but I mean I cracked all my
mistakes did you bring the makeup
remover well here's the thing
the thing is I never took it out so it
has to be okay great I think yeah yeah
oh no no totally it's cuz I'm doing
makeup tonight it is great I think I
think also I mean this is I mean it's
gonna be such a big day for us tomorrow
for so many reasons first of all Jackie
and I have the honor of partnering up
with Access Hollywood and doing they're
covering their their carpet coverage but
bigger than that is I'm showing my arm
for the first time like in years I'm not
like an arm like shower just like it
doesn't feel natural to me I didn't even
do it in Miami when I was embracing my
inner thought which I should have
because it would've been good like a
test run and I'm wearing a jumpsuit that
has one sleeve so I'm jumping back into
life with one arm and in the spray tan
last night I had them contour I don't
know if it really worked but I'm just
I'm freaking out so like that's why it's
a big deal you know it's a huge deal
it's the unveiling of the arm and you
should all be there so two new Taylor
Swift's gonna be at the CMAs now they
say that every year you know but like
she's actually out of hiding this year
like oh that's and she went to the
[ __ ] Billboard I feel like that she's
like the CMA community is like she needs
to prove herself to get back in really I
feel like they've always stood by her
like she still write songs for little
town right song no she wrote and babe
sugar I might imagine if she like came
out and saying babe I would die yeah I
wouldn't know I wouldn't know because
I'll be on stage right um we'll see and
if she is we will do everything in our
power to get her on our stream I just
want to say like our stream is gonna be
so premium but there's one thing that I
can't say obviously that's gonna happen
you know it is we're gonna break like
major news oh yeah I already know what
it is but I promise a person that I
wouldn't tell them but they promised me
they would come to us and talk about it
it's gonna be really great yeah it's
exciting times yeah Everage one high
average my high yes i toast my high
should we bother jumping into the past
pie I think it's time to jump into the
fast side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast because so much is
going on this weekend I didn't even know
where to begin I know the world
unfortunately kept turning while like we
were visiting turning and kept burning
unfortunately so our first story is
obviously about the California fires it
is so sad checking it's so sad and I
keep the more I think about it the more
sad it is you know like the more I've
read about it the more sad it is and
then there's like the human element
there's the animal element there's the
firefighter element there's a nature
like environmental element I know like
it just won't stop did you see the video
then like there's also the celebrity
element no and we have to get to that
but I can't give them my time right now
like any five minutes here the elements
that I'm concerned about
did you see Whitney Cummings like doing
the Lord's work that's what I was
watching last night and I was just so
interested in like the logistics of
animals and Malibu wine Safari which is
now the wine Safari is that place in
Malibu that like all the Kardashians go
to other people from The Bachelor go
it's like a safari and they serve wine
and everybody pictures with Stanley the
giraffe and in essence they hold animals
in captivity it looks like it's a ranch
like it's like I don't consider that
nearly as bad as like a zoo but like but
they are in tactically like being
kidnapped but they're being kidnapped in
a mansion right and if I were to be an
animal being kidnapped I think I would
want to go to Malibu they're not in like
a fake glass ocean it's like a true
ranch they have like acres and acres
it's fun and they're with their fellow
animals and it's me and they have
giraffe there and it's like virtually
impossible to transport a giraffe like
they basically die every time but
Whitney Cummings was like they did it
for the hangover like you could do it to
save a life and then like and I
understand that like the getting the
humans out is a priority for sure but
they lied like they told everyone that
they evacuated all the animals and
people like board their horses they're
like rich people in Malibu who have
horses but don't have stables like their
horses live in apartments for their
horses and they told
them that they took they evacuated their
horses and they didn't but then her so I
was trying to keep up with everything on
her story and it seemed like she was
trying to be really patient but giving
them a benefit was being transparently
she's like I don't know she was like I
don't know if it was best for them to
keep Stanley there I'm trying to get a
vet and an expert to come and tell me
and she was keeping it very open-ended
and truly trying not to put the blame
because whoever when she spoke to her on
the phone clearly was concerned they
love animals but like right they can
only do so much then I looked at another
girl
I forget her name she's working with
Paul works and she'd like 500,000
followers and homegirl was there at
Malibu on Safari she brought the exotic
vet and she said that they're all okay
what the giraffe didn't have any lung
inhalation he was totally fine there was
one Pig that had asked it like I'm so
freaked out cuz he saw a fire that he'd
escaped to the pen and got like burned
or something but he's okay Wow
so they actually might have done the
right thing by not evacuate I don't know
look I just don't know I mean I'm not
having an exotic vet so I don't really
know what the proper protocol is but to
me it's like the lying is the murky area
right right anyway so that's just like
one element of it and the human element
like I've literally been retweeting
things on Twitter people are like I
found this lady like does anyone know
her because there was like a retirement
village or like a paradise an old-age
home for like people who like might not
know what's really going on and they
just like are wandering the streets
I can't yes a one town called Paradise
was just completely burned leveled in
total 42 people have died so far and 220
are still missing which is so sad and so
scary and some of the reports were
saying that the flames were so strong
that like if someone did die like
they're just bone parts at this point
and like it'll take time make they're
bringing in DNA experts to identify
those bodies but it's not like they
found a body like their maid didn't even
think it's so crazy it's so scary did it
start
okay so then because Ben and I were
talking about he was like I heard was a
campfire no I don't hear that it's the
fire is called the campfire there's a
three fires going on but one's called
camp fire one's called Wolseley
I heard my hair blue yeah and then
there's a third one i but they all start
from the same source no but I know what
I read was that one of them started from
a power outage
spark and then the Santa Ana when it's
just like okay horrible tiny ruined and
oh dear I three we blowing
plus the dry land the bristle the trees
and it's just taking the state by storm
but we were talking about this the other
day and I can't remember if it was
because the fires had just started or we
just what happened to talk about fires
that sometimes the fires start because
it's just so dry and like it's just
worthless fiction sparks itself but this
one seems to have been man-made because
it was a electric electrical issue which
is just so tragic and I don't think like
truly that there's any worse way to die
and then being burned alive it's like
literally my worst nightmare
being burned alive in your car trying to
leave right and that's a thing it's like
whenever I hear of like like a Chaney a
natural disaster and it's like you they
give you a week like it seems like so
much time and now it's like these people
that are got ten minutes yeah there
wasn't even a way to evacuate
they died while evacuating oh my god
it's like there's traffic like right out
a small town like paradise like the
whole town doesn't ever have to leave at
one time so roads aren't made for it no
it's a boy i right it took like one hour
to go three miles and like so people
were just getting out and running and
this to me is like this is why life is
so unfair like we're all equal but like
people can helicopter and private jet
out of there while like a retirement
village people are running for their
lives like that's not there yeah we're
like just go rent a house get a hotel
rent a house like you know even just
like the basic like thing just getting
out yeah it's like I know this is gonna
sound so mean but like am I supposed to
feel bad for like like Miley Cyrus like
I know that's so mean to say like she
lost her house but like I don't know
it's like she got to jet chopper out of
there she got I literally died while
running on the freeway like I don't like
I don't know I know it's me to say but
no it's definitely sad to lose your home
for sure but most of the people most of
celebrities at least like have insurance
it's the memories and that's so sad but
there's it's way worse for for real
people and I just I can't heart I can't
stop like just okay like the people like
there was just so much going on like
this weekend this weekend and it's just
like it really proves how like out of
touch
so that Hollywood is like they go on and
like it don't get me wrong like that
baby to baby thing they did they raise
four million dollars and that's really
important but like them just like
getting dressed up in Black Tie gowns
I'm like taking pictures well literally
people like 20 miles up are being born
is alive I'm like you don't like you're
so dumb no when it's like it's so nice
that they raise four million dollars and
who knows if they would have been able
to do it without having a gala and
getting dressed up and taking pictures
black-tie but also all those people
could have gone up and started give your
planes
give your planes keep your plant or just
like volunteer no totally and it's like
when I saw I'd like everyone I'm just
like they see I mean it's easy for us to
say across the kind of course like
they're doing what they can but there
was a lot of things that were happening
this weekend that made me feel like
they're so out of touch so many award
shows going on celebrating absolutely
nothing right when miles away people are
burning alive I couldn't agree more and
it's like I don't want to [ __ ] on the
fact that they raised four million
dollars and baby baby is a wonderful
organization that does great work but
it's just like I don't know I feel like
we could have done better I don't it was
just really weird like which in between
the posts of like Love California also
like here's a $6,000 gown here's my
thigh slit at a black-tie gala I just I
was so like now more than ever they're
just highlighting like how hypocritical
and out of touch they are right I I
agree so anyways our first official
story has to do with the celebrity and
the natural disaster of it all Kim and
Kanye hire private firefighters to save
home and neighborhood Kim Kardashian and
Kanye West 60 million dollar mansion was
unscathed in the devastating California
wildfires thanks to a private team of
firefighters fire firefighters they
hired to battle the blazes the power
couple is being praised by neighbors in
their Hidden Hills neighborhood for
shelling out for a squad of smoke eaters
who dug trenches in order to keep the
inferno at bay TMZ reported Monday the
couple's mansion is situated at the end
of a cul-de-sac adjacent to a field and
could have threatened the rest of the
block had it gone up in flames neighbors
told TMZ that Kardashian and West saved
their homes
the couple were among many celebrities
who were forced to evacuate their homes
okay like how do you hire private
firefighters at it like is there a job
where like I'm a firefighter but like
privately maybe it's a retired
maybe or maybe it's firefighters from
other states right but like I just first
I just want to know more about the
logistics how do you go about hiring
private firefighters no I agree and like
why can't we all contribute to hiring
private private firefighters for other
neighborhoods right like where's the fun
for that right like I'll do it like I
can do any to the LAFD but at certain
point they only have as much resources
and beer everywhere as they have but
where do i donate to bring you another
firefighters from around the country
right no totally and like I've when I
first read this I was like oh my god
what I don't know how to feel about this
because like I said this just further
proves like the great disparities out
the right words between like rich and
poor it's like you can literally hire
firefighters to save your house but like
other people are truly like their shoes
are melting while they're running for
their lives like the disparity is so
real but homegirl saved the whole block
right so it's like good for you I don't
know no feel so I don't and also I mean
we are Kim sands and if someone else had
done this I don't know how I would feel
but I feel like it was her putting her
resources to good use like and it wasn't
like she stood she's old the
firefighters don't say that anyone
else's house right like she saved the
block right which would have by the way
comes that block I mean the next and the
next block just cuz they're rich doesn't
mean that they like so I'm here for this
I just wish we knew how we could do this
for more blocks and more people right
and yeah I when I read the headline the
headlines like a little misleading it's
like they saved their own house on page
six and they I think they just they just
added common neighborhood because I good
okay I don't know if it was there before
but it's there right and if I was rich
and I knew I could hire a private
firefighters to save my home where my
kids live for sure so like I don't know
I maybe I'm just a making being a Kim
apologist cuz I love her so much but
like good for her and she saved the book
right also it took her like so long to
find a home to live in memories she was
living in Chris's house is like imagine
if this home burned down six million oh
yeah and just say there yeah or like
live in a hotel I don't know it's not
the worst idea I've heard and she saved
her house and she saved her eyes did she
save the block this is just so crazy
honestly I liked really didn't
understand the gravity of it because
there have been fires before and they
like take over fields and people try to
like save the animals but it's never
been like it's real land
but these are really more densely
populated area this is like suburbs and
it's literally like biblical times no
it's crazy and it's and I was reading
like there it's gonna get worse before
it gets better like they'll probably
take another week to put them out like
it's not slowing down and then me and
Ben last night was just like talking
about it cuz like me Ben was like we
were just trying to come up with ways
like like we couldn't fix it and we're
like I literally I couldn't come on have
you seen the video of the planes that
drop that purple powder I don't know
what it is yes it's the Chris I don't
know what it is either and I've been
meaning to watch the miles teller movie
all weekend I was gonna watch it last
night but instead I chose to go to bed
at 9:30 which was the move for me total
I think I might watch it on the plane
after I do after I put together our
telenovela from Miami and by the way
Bethany be strong is involved
I saw her post something this morning
obviously it's so crazy cuz it's like we
can be the most technologically advanced
society that's broken but like there are
some natural things that we need like
nothing can help right no like even in a
hurricane if you had all the money like
you could get everyone out and you could
find places and people and give them
buries you you letting have anything you
rebuild right you can't imagine her Tina
you couldn't stop and you couldn't stop
the weather right so it's it's so crazy
it's literally like the most horrible
thing I've ever heard and like every
detail I hear just like makes me wanna
cry this morning I saw it like daily
mounted a write-up of like a lot of the
animals that have been affected and
there's literally this cat that's just
like burnt to a crisp and I don't even
know if it's alive or dead looks like it
was eating something is just like Burns
Tom it's so sad there's so many elements
that are so sad like the old people
running I can't like it literally makes
me want to cry yeah um moving on to
something that's not as sad but
definitely confusing mhm
Nikki Bella goes on a date with the
bachelorettes Peter Krause quote I don't
know if I'm ready does Nikki Bella have
a new man in her life in a sneak peak
from the upcoming season of total
Bella's Brie Bella sets her sister up on
a date and you might recognize him quote
Nicole gave me permission to set her up
on a date brie says before revealing
that the lucky man is Peter Krause from
The Bachelorette and while the twins mom
certainly seems to be on board Nikki
struggles with the idea of moving on
quote I feel like I'm 15 she says to
Brie as Peter tries to FaceTime her I
don't know if I'm ready for this ready
or not Nikki heads out
romantic night with Kraus after writing
gondolas Peter leans in for a kiss I
don't think it's unclear if they did
kiss right that the preview but this was
I saw this in the toasters and I was
shocked
well here's the thing I wasn't because
I've said it once I'll say it again the
world revolves around the morning toast
when Peter Krause was here I was just
reading questions for him like people
left up for him on Instagram and a
couple people were like why did
something keep Bella keep liking all
your photos so the association of them
the two of them wasn't so random the way
that they like are doing this organized
date like a [ __ ] episode of The
Bachelorette is weird but the two of
them together I wasn't surprised because
the trust knows everything yeah I I was
surprised I'm not gonna lie and even
though I like people like each other's
pictures randomly on Instagram all the
time is I can become a celebrity so like
yeah mana for with fellow celebrities
that would are like my dream girl yeah
and like honestly I know I'm obviously
just like bitter and jealous but like I
just don't think they're right for each
other no they're not right for each
other someone and the toasters set it
like like Peter is a catch a dream like
one of the most handsome Miss man's in
the world
it's a Miss but those things I don't
think is what nikki bella's looking for
no not at all
like John Cena and no offense it's not
like gorgeous he's like short like he's
you know a career man he's rich yeah
Peter Krause cannot give Nikki Bella the
white man's money okay here it is ready
Peter Krause cannot give Nikki Bella the
life she so desperately needs and is
accustomed to is it custom to who knows
what she needs but what's your cut once
you've tasted caviar it's hard to go
back to catfish is it not that Peters a
catfish no but like he lives in
Wisconsin not that that's bad but like
he doesn't live in a mansion like he's
not making that Ferdinand coin no maybe
he will maybe he will okay who do you
thinks the most money there's a great
night in my animated revival of
counselor and camper okay who do you sit
you could play camp director Jack focus
what is hard okay who do you think from
The Bachelor franchise everyone makes
the most money like from beginning til
I'm not Chris Harrison Lassie waters oh
yeah okay but like in modern time yeah
I'm like oldest season being like no I
know like happen and Shawn okay I'm
gonna
I'm gonna give you a couple names I'm
gonna throw out there Jordan Rogers does
okay okay I think Sean Lowe from
Bachelor fame does okay okay
yeah they have most of the lo & Co yeah
most of the the leaves mm-hmm do okay so
now we have to think about like
contestants you know yeah like I feel
like Marcus Grod like makes coin Marcus
and lacy
yeah no but I mean from bachelor Fame
not like in their home jobs that's like
jojo's I was talking the only boys
because they don't talk about everyone
oh no girls girls make so much money
like a minute who do you think makes him
oh I think we go Madison um Amanda Jojo
Becca Becca Lauren why they all really
came from like the same season yeah and
it was just like a gold rush yeah oh to
be alive to be alive
what's goodness I was thinking about
that the men who do you which men do you
think ooh such slim pickins for the
women it really is easier of course a
man posting outside fit fun I don't I
can't think of anything sadder
I can't think that that converts sales
you know you know but it's like that's
like a girl posting fact that kind it's
just so easy for them and they just make
so much a money hand-over-fist for the
men let me think
yeah probably Sean Lowe they said they
have a furniture line on Wayfarer that
does very well what about contestants
oh I'm sure Ben Higgins does well really
he works for a non-profit he does a
podcast so do we actually I
she's like she's she just it out she
says oh nothing she is the breadwinner
yeah in that relationship
of course yeah I know that looks like so
much but yeah no but she does okay
it's interesting to think about Corinne
I think Korea as well but I think she
could be she could be like I don't think
she cares like right she doesn't care as
much as the others yeah because she also
like had a job working in her guy like
she has a business yeah and um she
looked really cute at her birth she
looked so beautiful like we weren't
invited because we were weary but like
do you think a pair of New York should
have a meadow okay I think so do like
Richard Fenton we are she cried when she
saw me know
I love her so much I'm so happy so much
I'm so happy for her like she seems so
happy I'm just I love her
are you ready for the next story sure
cuz I I truly could I couldn't talk
about Nikki and Peter forever but I
could think about it forever no there's
really nothing to say you saw a
10-second clip let you say but I just
have like my yes no I've got nothing to
say
step out step i'm not sounding good
today
okay just wear a neck story i think this
is probably like just the most we keep
talking about things being out of touch
and something happened this weekend that
was the most out of touch thing please
tell me it's a revolver it is they're
evolved awards and the story that will
lead us in kendall Jenner avoids the
spotlight at awards show award show no
an award stage yeah at stage
fresh shows the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show runway
kendall Jenner headed to Las Vegas where
she received her balls icon of the Year
award Saturday but we hear she accepted
the award prior to the show and she did
not give an acceptance speech at the
lavish Fiji water sponsored event
honestly I didn't even know his sponsor
by Fiji I didn't even know his lavish a
source told us host Terrence Jenkins
explained that Jenner wanted to stay out
of the spotlight it will always shocked
me that his last name is Jenkins and not
J no it is Jeff OH source told us that
host Terrence J explained Jenner the one
thing that revolve did write and brought
them a little more back in touch turn to
Terrence J is the host of the century I
couldn't agree more and like he deserves
more work I want to see a show helmed
won by us but then another show helmed
by Terrence J Morton Stewart and
Charlamagne yes and also justin the lady
said i love him yes but then it's right
or they could each have their own job
but i'm telling you like those are the
four hosts that are going please i need
the shirt i mean to become a little bit
more mainstream this six hosts that are
go yes yes - we keep counting ourselves
out but because we're so humble by
sunday Jenner was back at it attending
the PCEs with her famous family I'm
sorry Jackie
bachelor person we forgot about Emily
Maynard she's rich okay I think she's
like home rich she was rich before rich
during rich after yeah I think she got
some money from Ricki yes I didn't she
came from family money I think she did
really well in the bachelors she wrote a
book she wrote a book a best-seller and
now I think she married someone from her
church to some girls are just like born
under a lucky star and Emily Maynard was
one of them Toth and some girls are just
like born to be rich like they're poor
version of them doesn't exist you know
no the poor version of me does exist but
I wasn't married for writing okay
the revolver where it's clawed take it
away I mean we were watching like okay
there were first of all the fact that
were involved as Awards is [ __ ]
hilarious like what like what are you
giving awards Harry awarding and to be
honest you see a face tune I would think
maybe a year ago maybe two years ago
like they really the awards like the
concept would have been a good idea like
just influencer Awards like there really
are influencers is such like a bustling
like economy let me see it's the digital
awards it's the Digi right like the
shores the web is the stream he's like
it should have been one of those partner
with a shorty especially because like
revolve was really one of the first
Brandt's like dive headfirst into
influencers and they they only recently
started getting like a real celebrity
talent but like for a while the only
thing they cared about was influencers
like I remember Danielle went on one of
their trips like two years ago when I
was like not nearly what it is now cheek
resting we were what and it was like in
Austin and it was like an in a nice
house with like four or five girls like
it was so different it's like wearing
the clothes perm or promoting or pop-ups
right and it was like really good and I
feel like they are just so weird now and
it's like they built their brand off the
backs of people like Danielle and like
all these bloggers and now all they care
about it's like Olivia culpo and roomies
rigid no but even though let me talk
about putting her in the back a people
they care about is in Victoria's Secret
models Emily Ratajkowski and Shay
Mitchell you know it's like so stupid
how like it's like mean like they these
girls literally built the brands and now
like revolve couldn't care less about
them and like they still throw them a
bone and invite them every once in a
while and this is they did they were
evolved words last year too and it
didn't strike me as so out of touch as
it did this year right like okay I kind
of the year Kendall Kendall Jenner for
revolve like well kendall Jenner I kind
of the year wearing a dress that I wore
to my birthday one year about one year
ago what about that is iconic for we're
thinking fashion-forward question mark
question I wore that dress a year ago
and so did Haley Baldwin like that dress
had its moment a year ago and you're
receiving an icon award
a year old dress maybe she wants me
reflective of the year that she won the
award I hope so Michio but it's like
give me something iconic to work with
yeah no that was weird and it's just
like all they care about now it's like
spending the most amount of money on
things that you can see so my probably
my favorite part of the awards was
watching revolves Instagram story like
this stage was gorgeous like they spent
all their budget on the stage and they
turned the camera around like once and
they have probably 50 people like
sitting in a conference room like the
conference like there was no it was like
it was a ballroom like there was carpet
and like chairs I would say you if
you've ever been on like a corporate
trip you've been in that bar and the
stage was a Grammy level with the neon
signs and then you turn around like
these people are getting up from chairs
like that I would break if i sat in yeah
like no bueno
and also I feel like they were so
thirsty like before like announcing like
the nominees and stuff and then like
when the winners like they never
announce the winners I didn't see it
anywhere and then two days later it's
not on there instantly
Helen Owen is the best breakout star and
I don't know what she broke out from
this year because she's been around
forever on trees I remember we were like
well because because we found out she
was dating zack kalter from The Bachelor
and he was on The Bachelor four years
ago they were like I remember when we
discovered Helen Owen one and she was
already out a million followers it was
when we were in LA centuries ago um as a
family remember when they threw up in
the bed that trip no but okay we throw
up in the bed it was literally two and a
half years ago okay it was we had a
crazy night out at Sur oh yeah I tried
to blame it on her yeah I remember all
you have to do is say oh yeah that's
when I knew about Helen Owens so I don't
know how she broke out this year
specifically um but I don't understand
yeah no like so stupid so out of touch
so out of touch I can't and I chant and
I want to know and it's just like as
much as I like for a while like hate
were evolved just because they're so not
inclusive and so out of touch with
reality like I really do think that like
in the in the influencer space like they
really like revolutionized
revolve I agree they revolutionized like
influencer marketing using like
influencers as models using influencers
as advertising and for a while that even
though they were knowing and not
inclusive they were smart business-wise
now like their priorities are so out of
whack like them sending that
he asks private plane for like Olivia
culpo Romi sure jet and all the other
models who they've forced to be there
like was so sad like I really thought
that point was gonna go down it was set
for Cedar that's flying across the
country these girls are so tall there's
no leg room they would have been more
comfortable flying coach
totally it was truly shocking and and I
agree with you but I also disagree too
because I do love revolve like as a
ecommerce red clothing web site if I the
only if I want to order something and
have it in one or two days and I want as
many options in the world revolved okay
a few things they're not great at being
inclusive you know in sizing sizing etc
and these awards show but overall like I
really think that they like are the
answer to all the problems we have at
Bloomingdale's and Saks agreed because
they they get like brands you've never
heard of who cares they sell them in
this good [ __ ] like Bloomingdale's if
you haven't heard of it right so in so
many ways I'm here for evolve and I want
them to do well and they're doing so
well but just stuff like this it's just
come on like everyone's sitting around
like applauding each other for posting a
picture in a bathing suit I couldn't
agree I can't I can't like it was so
stupid and like honestly like I really
and I don't feel like the streamys or
the shorties or the web he's like or
reflective with like the girls that we
follow and then like make fun of
secretly like there really should be an
award like best Instagram or like like
indifferent low like right best beauty
best lifestyle best humour like whatever
like there shouldn't be something like
that like I don't think this shorty the
shorties are like to digital and
revolvers I think we're gonna do a good
job in then they want it to be too
celebrity like we really need like best
morning show you know ya know we need a
better or we need the toasties done I
think we should put together like an
award show honestly I think we should
start a Kickstarter and wrap it around
Kickstarter will fund it and like we
just need like a million dollars and
we'll do it and we'll come up with all
the nominees and everything yeah and
like anyone can come like we'll try and
rent out MSG like for free yeah okay so
if you were to do like best award show
best and also critical it would be fan
boated and I want to see what the fans
vote for know what numbers like we
weren't talking about American Idol like
how did Maddie poppy win American Idol
and I
saying how Gabi Bauer couldn't win cuz
she like ready went on tour with Luke
Bryan they didn't want to probably
didn't want a man to win so Matty Papi's
boyfriend couldn't win and it's like who
should have won and I'm like what if the
people chose right now what's the vote
and every award show markets themselves
as like fan voting no no I want numbers
I want crunch those numbers I want a pie
graph I really want to know who people
think is the best beauty influences
totally and it's like just because I
think someone's the best beauty
influencer like doesn't mean that's
correct right the majority does rule
like I really think that it's way more
interesting to know what the people want
then like who which influence are you
want to push I think we should do it I
think we should too maybe they just
start first as like a digital thing we
would need someone to build the website
for us cuz I want to show the numbers
yeah I would want best that's like
Beauty influencer best fashion
influencers fashion influencer like best
digital show and obviously we're gonna
put ourselves up but we're not gonna rig
it we're also like the only digital show
totally and like the best but then I
also want like best photography like bet
like someone's pictures who just look
incredible best bachelor alum Brad best
bachelor content yeah or like I want to
go with us bachelor influenced or post
bachelor success but I want to go like
scrubbing in verse off the vine verse
yeah Olivia these fake podcast Taylor's
fake podcast like I want to put them
against each other
hit them all against each verse jeans
11:11 make a wish like biggest thirst
trap 11 don't have to make a wish that
we one day get this award show done make
the choice geez happen you know like if
you own operate a like a conference
facility we'll start there yeah we're
off we revolve did it we can if you
build stages and want to give us one for
free I'll take that too if you're a
sponsor you want a sponsor or hit me up
and if you know how to build a website
that counts votes let me know yes
SurveyMonkey
what else okay speaking about of
speaking of out of touch Victoria's
Secret faces backlash after execs
comments about trans and plus-size
models oh my god this was so crazy this
was so crazy hours before the 2018
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show tape in
new york new york spear who 94 on
Thursday though published a joint
interview with the lingeries Giants
chief marketing officer Edie Raziq and
Monica Metro exec VP of public relations
in their discussion Raziq was asked to
explain why the
annual spectacle does not include
transgender or plus-sized models in his
response which included the use of the
world transsexual the word transsexual
an outdated an offensive term Razzaq
said that the trans and plus-sized women
do not exemplify the quote fantasy that
Victoria's Secret is trying to sell
quote shouldn't you have transsexuals in
the show no no I don't think we should
well why not because the show is fantasy
he told the publication it's a 42 minute
entertainment special that's what it is
Raziq said that he and the Victoria's
Secret team have previously thought of
casting trans and plus-size models but
ultimately decided against doing so
shocking quote if you're asking if we've
considered putting a transgender model
in the show or looked at putting a
plus-size model in the show we have
we've invented the plus-size model show
and what our sister Division Lane Bryant
right still sells public size lingerie
but it tells a specific range just like
every specialty retail on the world
sells over into clothing as do we we
market to who we sell to and we don't
market to the whole world we attempted
to do a television special for plus
sizes in 2000 no one had any interest in
it still don't yeah well when you make
it like that we're gonna make a special
runway that's big enough for these women
like please just like put everyone in
the same [ __ ] I can and while he's gross
what I can't is like with like certain
models trying to make like their moment
off of this interview like there are a
couple plus sizing transgender models so
we're like trying to campaign for
themselves now it's like please [ __ ]
that's my job no and also like there is
a big difference between Bella Hadid and
a plus-size model there's a whole
category of women jog you tell me we say
in there it's grow there's a whole no
but like even like me like not and I
shopping he says we cater to who the
people that shop at our store I'm sorry
if I have a body like Candice Swanepoel
I'm not shopping at Victoria's Secret
I'm going around naked people not only
that my body like Kenneth Swanepoel I'm
obviously gonna catch a rich ass man and
he's gonna make me my own lunch you know
and I'm gonna shop at La Perla no get
that no offense so like people who are
sizes like a setter I'm not plus-sized
and I'm not Bella Hadid and I could shop
at your store so you're not catering to
the people who shop at your store right
we need more about Barbara Palvin of the
world the more I see I've heard the more
I love her checking me too and like the
dylan sprouse of it all I can and I've
been like looking at Sports Illustrated
and trying like we were gonna put
together a slideshow of models who we
who we would want to see
so but then we like got so caught up and
looking at them that we got too shocked
and Barbara Palvin is one of the few
Victoria's Secret models who also does
Sports Illustrated does she do boats
yeah and not and I always thought it was
one or the other well maybe maybe you
can't is she an angel she might oh you
know Qi is I think she's a pink model or
she just as a walker right I don't think
you can be an angel there's like
different levels there's something just
models there's some pink ambassadors
there's some angels you definitely can't
be an angel and bein sports I'll show
them no I don't know but then like Tyra
Banks was both right but Tyra Banks is a
special right
I don't know she's great anyways no
matter whether she goes a lot of
celebrities are dressed her up from her
head mm bright shine fire don't be
shocked you stop where you live where
you are based very high a lot of
celebrities are taking major umbrage
with these seals GG gorgeous of course
Amy Schumer I saw of course test
Holliday um who else well here's the
thing the thing is the model of Lyon its
I saw that but it's just so funny cuz
like the people like who should be
speaking out against it and normally
would can't because they're in the show
do you know they I'm like hey I don't
know I feel like GG loves an opportunity
to say something about something right
and she would he got me having two
tweets of this yeah but no she can't
she's under contract totally
interessante I wonder if this will
change a next year give in like the
backlash and Victoria's Secret released
a statement did you say yes it's
definitely in this article please read
this important message quote from at
from Edie quote my remark regarding the
inclusion of transgender models in the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show came
across as insensitive I apologize to be
clear we absolutely would cast a
transgender model for the show we've had
transgender models come to castings and
like many others they didn't make it but
it was never about gender I admire and
respect their journeys to embrace who
they really are
and it's like what is he trying to say
that transgender people don't shop at
Victoria's Secret
why their boobs - right
so stupid like and like how was Victoria
Secret everywhere like it's literally
the biggest band ever they've stores all
over the country I mean all over the
world but like well 5% of the world's
commitment and even if I could fit in it
it's like [ __ ]
it's literally made from [ __ ] and it's
$60 bras I guess because of their
marketing spearheaded by Edie some he's
onto something
no but you know what I mean like what
sets it apart from Arry why can't area
achieve that right try as they may try
as they may I don't know great point
sister right whatever [ __ ] them I'm just
jealous on his life everyone should know
like everything I mean about like I'm
jealous like Mike and Marco but but
we're not even mean about her I'll see
loved her know like I am I died for her
late honestly all I wish is though that
she would like to one more hallmark
movie just like you maybe yeah also
speaking of Megan Marco like you saw a
deal or no deal is like being thirsty
about Cassidy they're doing like a
behind-the-scenes behind-the-scenes of
how you get cast and it's like I don't
give a [ __ ] about anyone
show me Megan Marco's casting tape I'll
watch it
Megan Marco welcome to your tape I lots
of that on repeat of course it's like
Harvey what's his name
bald man hair America's Got Talent
Harry Harvey no Harvey no I think it's
Harvey Harry it's her and even Howard
Howie my boy Howie
ha Howie was like you can be on No Deal
and you never know what's gonna happen
and it's just like you could become a
princess right come no no no give me
that bad yeah nobody separate okay
there's no face we're both the girls
okay
this will hold this will this one to a
princess who's way too hard okay clean
the vinyl story just to shake things up
she get up Chicago
Celine Dion announces a children's
clothing line with a bizarre new video
what Celine Dion is getting into the
children's clothing market and acting
apparently the singer 50 debuted a short
video announcing Selena nunu which
appears to me as general neutral
clothing line for children on social
media Monday morning in the video
deonna's
so to the ground by a police officer her
still laughing from happy why was that
so hard
in the video deonna's wrestle two to the
ground by a police officer who pins her
hands behind her back
it's okay it's okay she says I'm Celine
Dion the Selena new new website lists
sweat shirts jackets the one Celine nunu
that's the name of the brand yeah spell
it
Cele and you and you and you
Selena new new it's all one word yeah
Selena gnam this is it Selena nunu
Shalini new new new yeah website list
sweat shirts jackets leggings and
t-shirts available for $42 two sixty one
hundred and sixty one dollars and baby
clothes such as hats and one disease
quote Selena nunu unites nights to
forces by one voice fashion has the
power to shape people's minds inspire
your children to be free and find their
own individuality through clothes bait
dreams there are also photos featuring
phrases like raise boys and girls the
same way and quote you are entirely up
to you that's very cute very cute Deon
has three sons of her own SoundCloud
rapper Rene Charles and Jahlil uh and
fraternal twins Eddie and Nelson anchovy
L both eight years old
excuse me did you say SoundCloud rapper
yeah that's what that's at page six
style I thought you said that as a joke
no she's a son who's a SoundCloud rapper
yeah Rene Charles Anjali oh and I didn't
realize that was a formal title I
thought there was a joke like I said no
like that to go to his some grimy
Charles on Jaleel SoundCloud and it's
like why can't he got a record deal his
mom is right is sling young miss Celine
Dion how many followers just yes hold on
um he's chopping he's he's topping the
charts of SoundCloud their chart songs
oh no well here's the thing I think this
is a great brand and the world
definitely needs the brand I just heard
what the world needs it to be brought to
us by Celine Dion I think it's so weird
when celebrities like randomly change
their like careers yeah I mean oh he has
1,800 followers on Sina on soundcloud
his last post was
three months ago and it got 5,000 513
listen play it it's called right now put
the speaker of his most popular one oh
wait never stop okay so he wrote a song
about using his mom's money
no no basically it's just like I grew up
rich is my mom Celine Dion and it's like
rapping about it right and then he
counted cards it's like why would you
admit to that I don't know oh it's not
the worst thing I ever heard like at
least he's trying
you know no it might be the worst thing
I've ever he should know find another
career path know he's rich he could do
whatever he wants like race cars I'm not
gonna feel sorry for him if all the
people we spoke about today like not
gonna feel sorry for Brittany Charles
and Julia is there anything and when you
spoke about today you feel bad about um
yeah the victims of the California a
while oh I feel badly about yeah Rene
Charles yeah his heart won't go on yeah
and like you want a cup of grab me like
I'm sure your mom's office is sadly she
Grammy's and storage like to remember
when he said he was a mini 21-7 she
wouldn't notice if one went missing no I
can't believe to get on a plane to go to
another land after this I know but like
it's gonna be crazy when you step off
and you're in another land and I didn't
pack well or at really anything I didn't
know I packed better than I did for
Miami cuz I knew the things that I
needed
um I still didn't bring a deodorant cuz
I can't find mine and mine is just like
stopped working completely by the way me
too I'm immune to my deodorant no and
now I'm all about Zacks because I'm all
about perfume now and spraying it in my
hair because like if your hair smells
good it does matter where your armpits
smell like know I'm all about perfume
and what's hard about fortune for me I
feel like I'm one of these people like
perfume doesn't stick on me jackée me
too
I could hurt if you put it aside and
smell them from a mile away that's not
good either no but like at least they
have like a vibe ascent to them like for
me it's like I'm spending all this money
on perfume and the minute I walk out the
door it leaves me I couldn't no I don't
I put perfume but if you put it in your
hair it really stays it might stay even
too long also you can't travel with
perfume because it's liquid and if it's
more than three fluid ounce it first of
all I could crack and like that's just
annoying and if it's more than three
fluid ounces it cracks I mean I can't
even talk English um it'll take a get
taken away and like sir I spent $60 Oh
60 that's a bargain actually I got it
for free and I'll be are back eh I'm
Giorgio Armani thank you but it's like
even free perfume that's you know we
always talk about perfume marketing how
it's like so hard to buy a perfume cos
came told me to when I can't smell it
right can't return it
that's why tempered is great because you
can actually like choose samplers and
it's like it's a perfume subscription
service and every month you get like a
perfume bottle and it's a reasonable
size so you can tell with it you can
leave it in your purse so that when your
perfume doesn't stick to you like it
doesn't for most ashtrays out here right
now what is it about Jewish skin no I
have no idea like just something did you
pack it in Minnesota because we were
able to sample a bunch of perfumes so I
got some of my favorites and some things
I wanted to try like mosquito fresh but
it's like you can't try a perfume unless
you go to the store and sniff it and
then you got a headache
you can't like order it and try it
because no also on a night out like when
you do when you change your lipstick a
spritz in the hair can save a lives can
save a life and so these are like
they're not
sample size like you got in a magazine
but it's like you're bigger they're
bigger they're better they come in this
really cute nifty case so it doesn't
spill in your bag I hate when I saw that
I was like I didn't order this what is
it I didn't know what it was I was like
did I get like fake versions of the
perfume I'm like oh great this generic
no but when you twist it out you see the
bottle comes out and that's all the
perfume smells like designers everything
and have you ever finished like a full
bottle of perfume yeah I never have but
then I was using a perfume for so many
years and then I felt like my partner
and I became immune to it and it started
to smell weird on me so I like the idea
of switching up perfumes not too often
but with Sanford you get a new perfume
every month and we have a wonderful
offer to you with our offer you'll get
50% off your first month today so that's
only seven dollars and fifty cents for
your first perfume that scent bird calm
scen t-bird calm slash toast and use
code toast for 50% off your first month
s cen t-bird dot-com slash toast sign-on
smell amazing take it with you I can't
look when I smell there's nothing like
you just have to go home like and
there's nothing worse there's nothing
now I'm afraid we're gonna smell the
same is maybe we should pick up a new to
you I brought my sunburns no no but we
should have a new geodon - we must what
you don't you use well I was using dove
and the clinical care wine Madhu which
is like the stronger one so don't mean
to that I think I need like men's now or
I just needed or like I need secret
clinical care I don't even want a smell
I just want unscented I used to use dry
idea and it was like really embarrassing
cuz like they didn't even sell it it was
like literally you needed a prescription
for it I used to be really smelly now
that I think about it I used to have
like the smelliest feet I'm like my oh
my shoes smelled I grew out of it like
that defeat in particular when I was a
kid I used to have to put special powder
in my shoes the closet used to start
smelling yeah and I just kind of grew
out of it I used to leave my shoes on
the terrace yeah I remember that but
then it just like stopped isn't that
weird that is really weird and now my
shoe look I don't have smelly feet
that is the weirdest thing maybe was
just like a puberty thing perhaps or
maybe like I was beyond police to go to
school for like ten
today just like running around being
like savages yes so maybe that's what it
was exactly like working hour you go
home take your shoes on right and like
yeah but now you're like traveling I
know I'm really can't I can't get on a
plane right now I don't want the show to
N because they don't wanna go to the
airport I feel the exact same way and I
want to get if we pass in like an anti
enzyme getting and also like I hope that
bird takes forever okay so was it with
you yes go into Miami no sometimes I
just like can't get out of an uber I'm
just too tired and sometimes I can't get
out fast enough yeah that's the life
since the life is a lot this is also
scheduling for the rest of the week
here's what's happening this is all
right getting de minimis she'll oh man
what are the words in that song oh yeah
okay here's what's going on tomorrow
tell me you can get a taste of the
morning toast on access online Facebook
and YouTube and YouTube and I'll get you
links before they told us they can
generate them there if you are into news
what's necessary you will find our live
stream and you know what put it up on
YouTube on your TV and just have the
most premium experience I know I'm like
jealous I like what you guys aren't
gonna get also there's no standard
episode of the toast tomorrow because
you will be getting your toast all
evening also I'm gonna do a master post
in the group about like questions you
want us to ask the labs because we were
saying like we need to do research and
look at all the subs Instagram so we
know what's pertinent the good I don't
want like Julianna questions what
inspires you and you guys plan your
outfit coordination no I'm not I'm gonna
ask people who are there wearing unless
I can't think of anything else unless I
just know unless they actually just know
if I'm asking someone who they're
wearing it's because I truly can't think
of anything else to say
fun fact okay then Thursday we will have
an episode for you of the toast podcast
only you know recapping the CMAs
satisfied may be a little slow v because
it'll probably be a treacherous day and
then Friday we are back in studio here
in these chairs for the last show until
after Thanksgiving oh really
and also the last show ever streaming on
Facebook Ravis food and so then the
whole week of Thanksgiving we are out
and then we are also out the Monday and
Tuesday following me are back
on Wednesday but for Thanksgiving we are
gonna do a fast five everyday writing
we're gonna do patreon episodes over
things in five days five days all of our
family members just you know thirsting
them out putting yeah Oh totally please
like this showcase or else like the
interview with Olivia and Zach that you
know we've been waiting for know that
we've been promising and not doing right
it's because like we've just been so
[ __ ] busy we haven't all hung out
like ever I'm just I'm so excited to sit
down
so again tomorrow because someone said I
didn't say where I'm streaming tomorrow
but I know that I did on Access
Hollywood Facebook and YouTube pages at
access online and access online it'll be
starting around 5:30 Eastern Time so
when we're there it'll be 4:30 right and
we're gonna be in another land
it's gonna be like hours worth of
content so enjoy thoroughly and we will
see you in these here chairs on Friday
anything else you would like to say um
if you are coming to my show in
Nashville please bring me snacks I just
have a feeling I'll be hungry you know
you know the food at Sandi's Nashville
is so good I'm gonna I'm gonna eat
actually afterwards cause like I've been
just getting diarrhea from like whatever
I eat and I don't want to I agree on
stage I can't believe that I haven't had
like a poop attack on stage yet or like
a sneeze attack I haven't even sneezed
on stage now that you said it I'm gonna
like shart while I sneeze oh my god I
love a good shark joke you know I love a
good I love anything on a shark well
with that have an amazing day everyone
we will see you live tomorrow from the
cma red carpet make sure you're tuning
in to the Access Hollywood Facebook and
YouTube pages to see your girls making
it big time and division follow us at
the morning toast at Jackie O problems
at girl with no job club with no job for
all of our national content and then at
puffles no job at tiffany thornton
congratulations on giving births for
just premium content all the way logo